Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Erster Mai Spaß dabei. Logbuch Netzpolitik, die 101. und revolutionärste Folge seit jeher.
Die revolutionäre 18-Mal. Die revolutionäre 18-Uhr-Folge. 18 Uhr, dem 18 Uhr, dem 18 Uhr, dem Kreuzwerk, das ist immer das entscheidende Momentum der Weltrevolution.
Ich möchte nicht, dass wir den Eindruck machst, wir hätten uns nicht früh morgens hier rausgeschält aus dem Bett.
Sogar um das mal hier zu zeigen, unter welchen Bedingungen ich hier geknechtet werde, eine Stunde früher als sonst am Feiertag. Und dann kommt der Tim 10 Minuten zu spät.
So ist das. Opfer werden gebracht. Aber für die Revolution ist uns ja nicht zu schade. Nachdem wir jetzt die Revolution letztes Mal zu Gast hatten, die fleischgewordene Revolution, die institutionalisierte Revolution, schön gesagt. Jahrelang war das ja so die Staatspartei in Mexiko. Ich glaube mittlerweile sind sie auch wieder in der Macht, die PRI. Das heißt ja tatsächlich die Partei der institutionalisierten. Bei uns heißt es Hans-Christian Ströbel dann und das ist nicht an der Macht. War aber auf jeden Fall ein schönes Gespräch mit interessanten Einblicken. Wer es noch nicht gehört hat, schnell nochmal zurückspulen.
Ich kann selber nicht viel stolz darauf sein, weil er ja geredet hat. Ja, wir haben ja nur gefragt. Aber das ist schon etwas, worauf ich stolz bin.
Naja, auf jeden Fall denke ich mal, das kann man auch mal wiederholen. Es sind ein paar interessante Ideen und Feedbacks da zurückgekommen für weitere Spezialformate und Ansätze hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Aber heute machen wir mal wieder ganz klassisch Nachrichten, Ticker, plus, plus, plus.
Bundesregierung will Snowden nicht einladen, Doppelpunkt. Staatswohl, plus, plus, plus. Das ist echt eine krasse Geschichte. Hast du das mal, also hast du mitbekommen wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ja, also weil man, dann will ja vielleicht der Geheimdienst nicht mehr mit uns zusammenarbeiten.
Genau, es gibt eine Stellungnahme der Bundesregierung an den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Das deutete sich ja schon an, dass es diesen Konflikt geben würde, denn wir erinnern uns, vor kurzem ist ja der Clemens Biniger vom Vorsitz dieses Ausschusses zurückgetreten. Genau, und sagte, ja, irgendwie mit dem Snowden, das wird mir hier irgendwie, nee. Und diese Stellungnahme, da wird also dann gesagt, ja, wenn dieser Snowden hier eingeladen wird, ist mit schweren und dauerhaften Belastungen des Verhältnisses mit den USA zu rechnen. Die nachrichtendienstliche Kooperation wird zumindest vorübergehend eingeschränkt. Und man hätte außerdem Zweifel, dass man seine Sicherheit, für seine Sicherheit garantieren kann. Und deswegen sagt die Bundesregierung, sie würde dieses Ersuchen, Edward Snowden in Deutschland anzuhören, nach Deutschland einzuladen, hinter das Staatswohl zurückstellen. Allerdings bietet sie an, in Russland könnt ihr den gerne befragen. Allerdings müssten die Untersuchungsausschussmitglieder dann mit strafrechtlichen Problemen in den USA rechnen. Das zumindest geht aus einem Gutachten einer US-amerikanischen Kanzlei hervor, dass die Bundesregierung sich da offensichtlich hat anfertigen lassen.
Strafrechtliche Probleme inwiefern?
Dass die USA nach Russland gefahren haben, mit dem Typen gesprochen, Geheimnisverrat, weiß ich nicht. Diese Schreiben, da steht ja jetzt nichts drin, was man sich nicht schon angekündigt hätte. Die Bundesregierung hatte deswegen ein Sagen mit drin, weil dieser Mann ja keinen Pass hat. Der ist ja nur ein Asylbewerber in Russland, der hat also keine Nationalität, die ihm jetzt eine ganz normale Einreise nach Deutschland irgendwie vernünftig ermöglichen würde. Und aus diesem Grunde muss die Bundesregierung quasi eine Rolle dabei spielen, wenn sie sagt, dieser Typ kommt in dieses Land, das heißt, sie müsste ihm eine Einreise- und Aufenthaltserlaubnis und eine Sicherheitsgarantie geben. Und das macht sie eben nicht. Und damit kann sie das auch verhindern, dass dieser Untersuchungsausschuss den Mann zu Gesicht bekommt. Schön und gut war zu erwarten, dass sie das tun würden, hat sich zumindest abgezeichnet. Jetzt kommt aber der Witz, diese Stellungnahme wird dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss irgendwann nächste Woche förmlich zugestellt. Jetzt fragt man sich, wieso hat sie denn dann jetzt schon die Presse?
Ja, aber Angie muss noch in die USA fahren.
Angie muss in die USA fahren. Und da möchte sie natürlich mit dem Freundlichen Gastgeschenk auftreten. Und nicht, dass da irgendwie in den Hinterzimmern und auf den Hauptseiten der Zeitung noch irgendwelche Konflikte oder Zweifel an der Loyalität bestehen. Und deswegen liegt die Bundesregierung, diese Stellungnahme an ihren Untersuchungsausschuss, eine Woche vorher an die Presse.
Die möchte wahrscheinlich der Folter entgehen.
Der Folter entgehen. Also ich meine, wie gesagt, es war zu erwarten, und das hat sich seit Wochen, Monaten angekündigt, dass sie irgendwie versuchen würden, das zu tun, das zu verhindern. Aber wie das jetzt passiert, das ist schon wirklich ein Skandal.
Also man muss sagen, diese Stellungnahme ist ja vom Untersuchungsausschuss angefordert worden. Es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass die Bundesregierung einfach mal so eine Stellungnahme gemacht hat, die dann auch dieser Untersuchungsausschuss dann sich mal anschauen darf. Es war explizit die Anfrage des UA an die Regierung und wie das halt so passiert. Manchmal liegt so ein Ding halt rum und komischerweise landet das dann auf einmal, weiß gar nicht, wer hat denn das überhaupt veröffentlicht, weiß man das?
Beim NDR ist das wohl angekommen.
Naja, das ist ja sehr staatsfern. Also, was soll man dazu sagen? Interessant ist natürlich diese Einschätzung als solche. Weil ich finde, das ist wahrscheinlich das ehrlichste Dokument seit langer Zeit in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Da steht im Prinzip drin, wir haben Schiss.
Der entscheidende Begriff ist ja hier der des Staatswohls. Und da gibt es einen interessanten Kommentar auch von Heribert Brandtel, der also sagt, naja, Staatswohl steht jetzt erstmal nicht direkt im Grundgesetz. Und es gibt aber natürlich diesen Amtseid, in dem gesagt wird, dass die Minister und die Kanzlerin ihre Kraft dem Wohle des deutschen Volkes widmen möchten. Also er stellt im Prinzip in Frage, dass das jetzt irgendwie eine legitime Begründung ist.
Das wäre ja auch eher Volkswohl.
Genau, Volkswohl. Der entscheidende Punkt ist, dass es eigentlich scheißegal ist, ob sie es darf oder nicht. Sie machen es einfach und damit hat sich das. Es wäre jetzt die Frage, oder auch Brandtl, der ist ja glaube ich sogar Jurist, sieht sich da jetzt schon so ein bisschen im Unklaren, was man dagegen tun kann, kann man wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Untersuchungsausschuss jetzt vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht ziehen kann und die Bundesregierung gezwungen kann, den Mann eben ist.
Nein, der Untersuchungsausschuss sowieso nicht, weil der ist ja überhaupt keine juristische Person in dem Sinne.
Also die Sache ist erledigt.
Weil die Regierung einfach sagt, nö.
Der Punkt ist ja, inhaltlich haben sie ja recht. Natürlich würden sie damit ihre diplomatischen Beziehungen relativ stark beeinträchtigen. Und sicherlich wäre das für Deutschland von kurz- oder gar mittelfristigen außenpolitischen Nachteilen. Es ist jetzt nur interessant, dass dieser außenpolitische Nachteil offensichtlich ein so großer ist, dass er direkt das gesamte Staatswohl, dieser Begriff wird ja hier bemüht, gefährdet. Das halte ich für ein bisschen übertrieben. Und das ist natürlich dann schon Feilkeit. Der Brandtild titelt da sehr schön in der Süddeutschen. Die Regierung versucht, ihre Furchtsamkeit zu adeln. Und das ist aber hier nicht unbedingt der Fall.
Also es ist, so nach dem Motto, es ist doch prima, dass wir so kleine Schüster sind. Das kommt uns doch allen zu gut. Ich meine, es ist sicherlich sehr schwierig, sich von außen den Druck vorzustellen, unter dem die Bundesregierung steht. Ich würde das jetzt mal annehmen, dass das durchaus ein spürbarer Wind ist im Kanzleramt. Meine Amerikaner machen, meine, wenn die mal Welle machen, dann das können die.
Das glaube ich, die haben das im Laufe der Geschichte der Menschheit mehrmals unter Beweis gestellt, dass sie echt eine extreme Welle machen könnten. Aber man muss natürlich auch sehen, dass dieser Schritt von, dieser Schritt Deutschlands, der deutschen Bundesregierung, geht natürlich über die einzelne Handlung der Bundeskanzlerin hinaus. Nämlich sie ist ja, warum auch immer, wir haben uns lange darüber gewundert, ein internationaler Dreh- und Angelpunkt auch dieser Affäre. Es war nicht nur für Deutschland eine große Wende in dieser Affäre, dass Angela Merkels Handy abgehört wurde. Es war auch für die gesamte internationale Sicht auf diese Affäre eine neue Wendung. Das hat andere Nationen auch stark interessiert, dieses Thema. Das war eine große Sache.
Was andere Nationen interessiert ist, aber erst einmal primär in dieser Frage, so nicht interessant für die Bundesrepublik.
Teil, denn es ist für die gesamte Welt natürlich jetzt echt mal eine interessante Perspektive zu sehen. Diese Person, diese entscheidende, alliierte Person, die irgendwie in einem Land regiert, was seit 60 Jahren, 70 Jahren annähernd seine Politik absolut auf den Schulterschluss mit den USA ausrichtet, selbst diese Person ist zum Opfer der Spionage geworden. Und selbst diese Person mit einem der bevölkerungsstärksten Staaten in Europa, mit der ganzen Europäischen Union als potenzielle Verbündete knickte absolut ein. Und das ist natürlich schon ein Signal in die Welt.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so ein neues Signal ist. Ja, also ich meine, sowas kennt man und das ist jetzt in dem Sinne nichts Neues. Und dass Deutschland noch nie eine besondere Rolle in der Revolution gegenüber den USA eingenommen hat, ist auch nichts Neues. Das ist eher nur so die Botschaft, naja, wir sind auch nicht bereit, das aufzugeben. Und von daher, schwer zu sagen. Ich meine, ich wäre jetzt überrascht gewesen, wenn sie sich für Snowden jetzt auf einmal hätten erwärmen können. Also hier passiert jetzt nichts, womit ich nicht sowieso gerechnet hätte. Es ist nur interessant zu sehen, welchen Weg sie gehen. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht machen sie sich jetzt auch ehrlich. Also sie sagen also wirklich, was hier eigentlich das Problem ist und wie sie das priorisieren. Und ihre Priorität liegt halt einfach darauf, dass wir irgendwann keinen Stress haben mit den USA. Und der Rest ist uns entsprechend weniger wert.
Richtig, richtiger Punkt. Aber wir liegen unsere eigene Stellungnahme an einen Untersuchungsausschuss früher an die Presse. Das ist ohnehin ein schlechter Stil, diese gesamte Nummer. Und dann auch noch das, ich muss ja nächste Woche irgendwie in die USA. Könnten wir das nicht vorher in die Presse bringen, weil dann spare ich mir da Ärger. Also da gibt es ja auch kaum noch irgendwie schöne Begriffe für. Das kann man jetzt auch nicht irgendwie noch mit irgendeinem Begriff belegen, der jetzt nicht... Das ist einfach Realpolitik.
Da kann man sich jetzt groß darüber aufregen, aber das ist halt einfach so ein Zoch. Ich meine, am Ende ändert es nichts. Also das Statement wäre ohnehin so ausgefallen. Gut, jetzt haben sie es halt vorher bekannt gemacht, um durch sie ganz erlassen, dass sie da irgendwie treue Vasallen sein wollen. Super, erbärmlich.
So, weiter geht es. In den USA nämlich.
Da geht es richtig ab.
Ja, wir erinnern uns, auch davon haben wir darüber gesprochen, die FCC hatte ja schon vor vier Jahren ungefähr eine Regulation für die Netzneutralität verfasst. Da hatte sie, ich glaube, das haben wir ja auch schon öfter erwähnt, im Prinzip ganz gute Regeln. Die waren jetzt nicht so die besten, die man sich vorstellen konnte, aber die waren erst mal relativ stabil.
Es roch nach Netzneutralität.
Es roch nach Netzneutralität. Man konnte da Kantspuren von Netzneutralität enthalten. Sie hatten dann, was ein bisschen kritisch gesehen wurde, eine Ausnahme für Mobilfunk. Das heißt, sie haben gesagt, Netzneutralität erst mal nur auf Landlines. Aber sie hatten eine. Die wurde ja im Januar von einem Gericht gekippt, Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete. Und jetzt war ja die FCC, es lag jetzt quasi an der FCC, nun eine neue Regulation zu bringen, die in Einklang mit diesem Gerichtsurteil ist. Und diese neue Regulation haben sie jetzt formuliert. Die ist jetzt quasi in einem Draft bald vorliegen. Dann können bis zum 15. Mai Kommentare dazu gegeben werden. Und quasi die Absicht ist jetzt erkannt. Und was sie sagen ist, sie möchten jetzt Pay-for-Play-Lösungen legalisieren. Das ist also dann, wenn ein Diensteanbieter für die letzte Meile Wegzoll zahlt. Das heißt, wir haben das ganze Internet, da drin fliegen Daten hin und her. Irgendwann kommen die im Rechenzentrum meines Diensteanbieters an und kommen von da dann durch DSL die letzte Meile zu mir nach Hause. Und auf dem Stück soll jetzt der Internetanbieter, den ich ja bereits als Kunde bezahle, auch noch in die andere Richtung kassieren können und besonderen Anbietern seiner Wahl dann nochmal eine gesonderte Rechnung stellen dürfen. Bleiben soll, darauf konzentriert sich die FCC gerade, das trägt sie stolz vor, das Blockieren von rechtmäßigen Inhalten soll nicht erlaubt werden. Allerdings das Geldverlangen für deren Zustellung. Also das ist der klassische Fall von YouTube. Das ist aber doch schade, dass eure Videos hier wackeln bei unseren Kunden, wo wir doch 10 Millionen Kunden haben, die jetzt keine tolle YouTube-Experience mehr haben. Wäre doch gut, wenn wir das Problem lösen könnten durch eine Überweisung von Dollargeldbetrag.
Schönen Dienst haben sie da. Wäre doch schade, wenn keiner guckt. Ja, wenn er ruckeln würde.
Und genau davor, in der Diskussion 2010 um die Netzneutralitätsregulation, genau davor hatte die FCC gewarnt. Es gibt Schriftstücke von der FCC, in denen genau drin steht Erwägung, Folgen. Das darf nicht passieren. Entsprechend muss unsere Regulation sein, ist unsere Regulation. Das war allerdings unter dem FCC-Direktor Julius Genachowski. Und heute steht Tom Wheeler der FCC vor. Tom Wheeler, interessant, ist ein Venture-Kapitalist, ein Funder für Obama. Der hat also sehr stark für Obama Wahlkampf gemacht. Und auf seine Initiative gehen um die 700.000 Dollar zurück, die der Obama-Kampagne zugekommen sind. Und er ist ein langjähriger Lobbyist genau jener Industrie, die er jetzt reguliert. Nämlich, er war bis 2004 bei der Cellular Telecommunications and Internet Association. Also einem Lobby-Verband für Internet- und Mobilfunkanbieter. Davor war er in der National Cable Television Association. Hier ein kurzer Exkurs. Tim Wu, der mit U aber geschrieben. Derjenige, der den Begriff der Netzneutralität geprägt hat, hat dieses Buch, The Master Switch, das ich auch teilweise schon an mehreren Stellen mal empfohlen habe, geschrieben. Und zeigt darin auf die Entwicklung von einem irgendwie neuen innovativen Markt mit mehreren Bewerbern hin zu eben dem Monopol der US-Kabel-TV-Anbieter, das jetzt seit auch wieder mehreren Dekaden existiert. Und er zeichnet also die Entwicklung nach, eben übrigens auch über Regulation, über tatsächlich Gesetzgebende und FCC-Regulation, wie es quasi die Markteintrittsbarrieren erhöht wurden und die Macht der Monopole ausgebaut wurde. Und das Interessante an diesem Buch ist, dass es bei diesem Kabel-TV eben losging, dass es dieser neue frische Markt war, der gegen dann wiederum andere existierende Marktmonopolisten sich durchsetzen musste, nämlich irgendwie Normaltelefon und so. Aber interessantes Buch. Und spannend ist, dass genau die Entwicklung Netzneutralität oder Abschaffung einer solchen sich beim Kabel-TV auch schon so damals abgezeichnet hat. Und er nimmt dies als Beispiel dafür, wie sich das bei dem Internet auch entwickeln könnte. Und jetzt der FCC-Regulator, der jetzt die Regulation macht, hat quasi die Erfahrung als Lobbyist der Kabel-TV-Assoziationen in den 90er Jahren oder sogar noch davor. Und dann als Lobbyist der aufstrebenden neuen Organisation des neuen Bereiches Mobilfunk und Internet. Dann hat er zehn Jahre lang sich nur noch als Kapitalist betätigt und ist jetzt Regulator in genau dem Bereich Kabel-TV und Telefon. Es ist unglaublich. Klassisch. Interessanterweise, um kurz zu erklären, wie solche Schritte dann erklärt werden. Als der vor einem Jahr, der in die FCC berufen wurde, haben natürlich, haben sie sich nicht entblödet, die Cellular Telecommunications and Internet Association auch ein Statement dazu abzugeben. Sie haben gesagt, das ist ein guter Mann. Begrüßen wir, dass unser Ex-Lobby jetzt der Regulator ist. Können wir Präsident Obama nur beglückwünschen. Dieser Mann steht der FCC vor und wird dort gezielt genau den entscheidenden Punkt der Netzneutralität abbauen. Er betont also, einerseits darf man jetzt legale Inhalte trotzdem nicht blockieren. Das heißt, man darf nur ruckeln lassen, aber nicht blockieren. Und man muss seine Netzneutralitätsverletzungen transparent machen. Transparent machen ist dann wahrscheinlich der Teil, wo man sagt, hier kannst du mehr bezahlen. Und es darf nicht ökonomisch unvernünftig sein. Das finde ich am schönsten. Das, was man tut zur Verletzung der Netzneutralität, darf nicht commercially unreasonable sein. Und das ist natürlich interessant, weil das, was auch immer du als Unternehmen tust, wird nicht ökonomisch unvernünftig sein. Das muss dir aber nicht der Regulator sagen, dass du dich ökonomisch sinnvoll verhalten solltest. Also sehr, sehr interessant.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ökonomisch hier wirklich die beste Übersetzung ist.
Kommerziell?
Ja, weil ökonomisch so ein bisschen auch diese Assoziation mitschleift.
Die Gesamtwirtschaft.
Genau, dass es so gut für alle wäre.
Kommerziell unvernünftig.
Ich meine, was ist denn das bitte für eine Regelung? Man muss den Firmen ja nun wirklich sowas nicht vorschreiben. Schon gar nicht, dass in so einer Regulierung irgendwas zu suchen. Was man ja auch nochmal verstehen muss, ist, diese neue Regelung, ist die jetzt eigentlich schon durch?
Nein, noch nicht. Also die steht jetzt zur Debatte. Jetzt ist natürlich das Geschrei entsprechend groß.
Das Geschrei ist groß, der Widerstand formiert sich. Ob das noch irgendwas bringen kann, das wird sich zeigen. Aber was halt jetzt hier im Prinzip passiert ist, dass, das muss man sich auch glaube ich nochmal klar machen, überhaupt nicht der ganzen Netzneutralitätsdebatte. Dieses Wort ist ja auch sehr schwierig. Ich meine, es beschreibt zwar an sich ein heeres Ziel, aber es ist mal wieder so ein sehr schwer zu vermittelndes Ding. Das hatten wir ja hier auch schon mehrfach. Was aber jetzt konkret diese neue Regelung bedeutet, heißt eigentlich doppelte Bezahlung. Weil man als Kunde bezahlt man halt einerseits seinen Zugang zum Internet, den kennen wir alle. Der ist ja auch gerade in den USA noch schlimmer als in Deutschland. Unglaublich teuer, also zumindest für hohe Bandbreiten an den meisten Stellen. Und dafür zahlt man halt Geld. Was heißt, man zahlt halt überhaupt Geld, dass die Daten überhaupt schon mal zu einem kommen können. Jetzt nimmt aber derjenige, der einem diesen Zugang kostenpflichtig anbietet, auch noch Geld dafür, dass über diesen Weg auch jemand gehen darf. Also es ist ungefähr so, als wenn man jetzt von der Gemeinde zur Kasse gebeten wird, dass das eigene Haus dann mit Straßenanschluss versehen wird, da muss man ja auch für bezahlen, dass dann sozusagen auch noch jeder eine Mautgebühr aufgedrückt bekommt, der einem dann auch noch besuchen will, zumindest wenn es schnell gehen soll. Ansonsten kann man halt einen Antrag stellen und dann dauert es halt so ein bisschen. Und dieses Double-Payment wäre glaube ich auch in der politischen Argumentation, also besonders in der politischen Gegenargumentation, glaube ich ein relativ wichtiger Punkt, dass man also hier klar macht, dass das hier Double-Payment ist quasi.
Hattest du nicht dieses Beispiel mal gebracht mit dem Zug, der in Hamburg losfährt, alle haben bezahlt und auf ein Weg nach München ruft der Schaffner dann in München an und sagt, ich bringe hier gerade 200 Leute zu dir. Verzeihst du, damit ich auch in München anhalte? Das war glaube ich der, ich weiß nicht, ob du dieses Beispiel gemacht hast.
Weiß ich nicht mehr ganz genau.
Das Konzept ist klar, noch kurz.
Es gab ja noch dieses Taxi-Beispiel, das war aber nicht von mir.
Taxi-Beispiel war aber Leistungsschutzrecht. Aber egal, egal, egal. Hinweis noch an der Stelle, warum ist das so schlecht? Also warum ist das so fürchterlich? Man könnte ja auch sagen, die Inhalteanbieter haben ja genug Geld. Können sie ja ruhig bezahlen. Das Problem ist, dass auch jetzt, wenn man nicht mit Menschen argumentiert, die gegen das Argument der Freiheit immun sind, also beispielsweise mit Angehörigen der CDU oder FDP, dann kann man denen erklären, dass das Markt Eintrittsbarrieren befördert. Dass nämlich in Zukunft ein Anbieter es schwierig haben wird, sich gegen die etablierten Monopolmächte in dem jeweiligen Bereich durchzusetzen. Und da kommt der Punkt, warum eine solche Regulation unter Umständen für besonders große Inhalteanbieter eventuär wünschenswert ist. Also gehen wir mal in die Ebene jemanden wie Apple mit seinem Media-Streaming-Dienst, jemanden wie Amazon mit ihren Filmen und Multimedia-Streaming-Sachen, YouTube bzw. Google mit dem großen Datenaufkommen. Die können unter Umständen sagen, wenn der Preis, den wir da zahlen, nicht allzu hoch ist, gemessen an dem, was wir an Umsatz haben, dann ist das eigentlich eine relativ willkommene Versicherung gegen Konkurrenten, um nämlich sicherzustellen, dass ein zukünftiger Konkurrent unseres Dienstes nicht in der Lage ist, diese Marktdurchdringung zu erreichen, die wir bereits jetzt haben. Und das ist das Argument, was jetzt auch so für jemanden, der bei Freiheit lieber an Markt denkt als an Menschen, ist das ein relativ wichtiges Argument.
Was ist mit dem öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk? Was ist die Bundesregierung und das deutsche System bereit zu bezahlen, dass ARD und ZDF künftig auch über das Internet ausgeliefert werden? Ich meine, dass das passieren werden muss, ist uns, glaube ich, allen klar. Aber kann dann quasi die ARD nur noch über YouTube und über Apple TV senden oder selber in der Lage, selber zu machen? Was für Kosten kommen denn dann darauf zu? Wenn jeder einzelne Provider noch mal die Hand aufmacht. Und vor allem, das bedeutet ja, dass letzten Endes für den Anbieter höhere Kosten entstehen. Wer zahlt die?
Für den Anbieter entstehen? Weiß ich nicht, wer die zahlt, werden wir sehen.
Na, der Kunde zahlt die, weil die Gebühren für eine Dienstleistung berücksichtigen halt alle Kosten. Und in dem Moment, wo die Auslieferungskosten steigen, und zwar ohne, dass dem jetzt wirklich ein wirklicher Gegenwert entgegensteht. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man dann auf einmal mehr dafür bekommt, sondern es ist so, dass man das, was man sowieso sonst bekommen hätte, gäbe es eine reine Netzneutralität, dass nur das dann wieder sozusagen erkauft werden kann. Im Prinzip ist das einfach alles Erpressung.
Es ist Erpressung. Da könnte man jetzt sagen, das ist commercially unreasonable. So viel dazu. Aber wir haben ja die lange Sendung zur Netzneutralität. Wir haben die Einlassung von Thomas. Und ich denke, der Punkt ist klar gemacht. Deswegen kommen wir zum nächsten Thema. Ich mach diese Woche die Überleitung.
Ja, okay. Ich vielleicht noch einen Gedanken zu Ende bringen. Auch auf die Gefahr, dass wir das alles schon mal erzählt haben. Aber ich denke, es ist auch immer ganz wertvoll, wenn wir mal so ein paar Talking Points erarbeiten. Das ist auch so ein bisschen... Das hat so ein bisschen was von Schutzgeldzahlung. Du machst deinen Laden auf, du zahlst Miete, bist an irgendeiner Straße, hast einen schicken Laden ausgesucht, hast investiert, hast da auch in den Ausbau bezahlt, hast deine Produkte bezahlt und so weiter, bezahlst deine Leute, hast deine Kosten, alles. Und jetzt wartest du eigentlich nur noch auf Kunden. Und dann kommt so ein Herr mit einem Backstein in der Hand. Das ist unser Lieblingsbeispiel hier, so ein schöner Laden hier. Das wäre doch sicherlich ganz okay, wenn jetzt auch Kunden kämen.
Nur, dass der halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, an der nächsten Kreuzung eine Straßensperre aufgebaut hat und sagt, die mache ich halt. Okay, wir haben jetzt 1000 Vergleiche.
Ja, aber das ist im Prinzip genau das, was jetzt hier ermöglicht wird. Dass selektiv Zugang versperrt wird. Weil, in der ganzen Debatte, ja, sie reden immer von added value und mehr und Zusatzdienste und so weiter. Das klingt immer alles ganz toll und shiny, dass hier irgendjemanden für mehr Geld, mehr Leistung verkauft wird. Das ist aber der Spin, der hier genau einfach in die falsche Richtung zeigt. Hier geht es nicht darum, dass irgendjemand mehr Leistung bereitgestellt wird, weil die Leistung wäre ohnehin schon da. Dadurch, dass andere für mehr Leistung zahlen, ist es quasi ein Weckaufen der Leistungen von den anderen, die nicht zahlen wollen. Und das ist das, was diese ganze Sache einfach so eklig macht. Das hier sind Schutzgeldzahlungen. Der Verbraucher zahlt einfach doppelt und dreifach und fünffach für jeden einzelnen Dienst, der überhaupt noch eine Chance haben will, nennenswert durchzukommen. Beziehungsweise er zahlt letztlich, wenn nicht direkt mit Geld, auch darin, dass die Dienstleistungen, die sonst besser wären, schlechter sind. Weil sich eben die entsprechenden Anbieter das nicht leisten können. Ich meine, ich als Podcaster, ich bin nicht in der Lage, jedem Internetprovider auf diesem Planeten, weil es ja auch nicht so ist, dass es eine einzige Stelle gebe, wo ich Geld einzahle. Und dann ist mein Zugang zu allen potentiellen Empfängern besser. Ich muss mich ja mit jedem einzelnen fucking Internetprovider auf diesem ganzen Planeten auseinandersetzen. Wenn ich meine Qualität hochhalte.
Das ist ja nicht das, was passieren wird. Was gewünscht ist, ist ja, oder was für alle Beteiligten außer dir ökonomisch gewünscht ist, dass du dich dann bei einem der großen Hosting- oder sonstigen Dienstanbieter mit deiner Meta-Ebene niederlässt, der entsprechende Regelungen mit allen Providern hat. Das heißt, die Idee, dass du überhaupt irgendwie selber einen Meta-Ebene-Server betreibst, der dann größere Datenmengen zu irgendwelchen Kunden schaffelt, die Idee soll es ja gar nicht mehr geben. Der Gedanke ist, dass du dann halt, weiß ich nicht, du kaufst dann schön deinen Amazon S3 oder Akamai, die haben das alles für dich geklärt. Sparst dir den ganzen Bürokram für nur so und so viel. Eine Rechnung, alle Anbieter, 90 Prozent Marktpenetration in deinem Zielbereich. Wenn du Eurasien auch noch dabei haben möchtest, musst du hier das Ozeanienbundle kaufen. Darauf läuft es ja hinaus. Also ich denke, für die einzelne Person, das Argument, mit dem ich auch eher vorsichtig bin, ja wir Blogger, ja wir Podcaster, für die paar Bits, um die geht es tatsächlich nicht. Also wir haben halt gerade eher ein Problem darin, oder das Problem zieht eher darauf hinab, dass alles im Prinzip zentralisiert wird und in jedem Bereich, wo man irgendwie im Internet Geld verdienen kann, entsprechende Monopole entstehen.
Beziehungsweise Oligopole. Na ja, also dass du jetzt hier mein persönliches Medien-Imperium einfach rausnimmst aus der Konkurrenzsituation, finde ich ja ein bisschen, aber ich lasse das mal gelten.
So, nächstes Thema.
Genau.
Das nächste Thema ist eins, der wollten wir eigentlich einen Gast zu haben. Ich habe es aber leider verballert, den Gast auch einzuladen, weil ich immer wieder irgendwie unterwegs war. Netmundial. Eine Konferenz in Sao Paulo. Wie spricht man das eigentlich korrekt aus? Sao Paulo. Zu der ich jetzt irgendwie gar nicht so viel sagen kann, denn wir erinnern uns, also Hintergrund ist, die USA haben ja angekündigt, unter anderem die ICAN-Rolle abzugeben. Und jetzt muss sich quasi das Multi-Stakeholder-Modell quasi irgendwie darauf einigen, wie denn in Zukunft die Internetaufsicht zu bewerkstelligen sei. Also wie wird das Internet ab jetzt reguliert oder beaufsichtigt und vereinbart von uns? Und den Auftakt zu diesem Prozess hat jetzt die NET Mundial markiert, wo dann Vertreter von den großen Diensteanbietern, den großen Inhalteanbietern, den großen Providern und auch eben Vertreter der Zivilgesellschaft, dann dort sind alle mit gleichberechtigter Stimme dann über ein Abschlussdokument diskutieren, welches dann am Ende so eine Art Absichtserklärung ist. Das ist jetzt noch nicht direkt mit irgendeiner Ahnung verbunden, aber überhaupt, dass man sich da auf Prinzipien einigt. Und da geht es dann natürlich um große Fragen, wie man eben Prozesse sortiert, unter anderem eben die Icon-Rolle, muss jetzt mal ausdiskutiert werden, und aber auch um so etwas wie Prinzipien bezüglich Netzneutralität und Überwachung. Und im Rahmen dieser Konferenz kam es dann zu Unstimmigkeiten bezüglich dieser beiden Themen, weil die vertretenden, die kommerziellen Vertreter dort, also es sind natürlich dann auch so, es ist natürlich dann zum Beispiel auch die US-Filmindustrie sitzt dann da, und die sagt dann irgendwie, ja, wir müssen alle Menschen achten und vor allem auch die Urheberrechte der Menschen, und deswegen wollen wir aufpassen, dass im Internet keine Gesetze verletzt werden. So was zum Beispiel. Solche Klauseln versuchen die dann da unterzubringen, das kriegen sie auch teilweise hin, und andererseits kommt dann ein klares Bekenntnis zur Netzneutralität nicht mit rein, sodass am Ende viele NGOs, quasi das, was sich dort die Zivilgesellschaft nennt, sich dem Abschlussdokument nicht angeschlossen. Weil sie sagen, ok, da fehlt was zur Netzneutralität und da sind zu stark verwässerte Klauseln zum Thema der Überwachung. So, das ist jetzt dieser Punkt. Die Konferenz als solche hat jetzt quasi noch nichts hervorgebracht, was die Internet-Governance-Debatte quasi abschließt. Die hat jetzt angefangen. Und da gibt es jetzt ein Abschlussdokument von der Netmundial. Und jetzt werden sicherlich irgendwie weitere derartige Konferenzen regelmäßig stattfinden.
Die Debatte ist eröffnet. Ich weiß nicht, hast du jetzt den eigentlichen Titel dieser Veranstaltung, also sie heißt Netmundial? Und was der eigentliche Subtitel ist, ist Global Multi-Stakeholder Meeting on the Future of Internet Governance.
Genau, also Internet Governance eben dieser Begriff, der quasi all das umfasst, was wir im Internet als gegeben annehmen. Wie gesagt, ICANN ist so das beste Beispiel, was mir immer einfällt, wo eben gesagt wird, ok, irgendwo muss es halt bestimmte Autoritäten geben, die das technische Zusammenspiel regulieren, sich aber ansonsten relativ raushalten. Und das ist dieser Teil, der dann auch weiß ich bei den Internet Governance-Foren immer besprochen wird, solche Dinge.
Das Ganze fand ja in Brasilien statt und offensichtlich hat auch die, wie heißt es nochmal, Dilma Rousseff die brasilianische, was ist sie eigentlich, Ministerpräsidentin?
Präsidentin.
Präsidentin heißt das genau.
Und jetzt zum Auftakt der Konferenz ihre Marco Civil da Internet verschickt.
Genau, also er hat sich sozusagen zeitlich da ordentlich rangewandt und da versucht, ein Statement zu machen, um selber da quasi für, ich glaube, auch Netzneutralität einzustehen oder kriege ich jetzt gerade was durcheinander mit der anderen Debatte?
Die haben also ihre Internetverfassung, in der sowas steht, alle Brasilianer haben das Recht auf einen gleichen Internetzugang, ihre Privatsführer, davon muss geschützt werden. Meinungsfreiheit gibt es im Internet. Provider sollen nicht für Inhalte haften, die Nutzer bei ihnen veröffentlichen. Metadaten dürfen nur eingeschränkt gesammelt werden. Also so eine allgemeine Verfassung für das Internet, die für Brasilien gilt und relativ wirtschaftsfeindlich ist. Also da gibt es auch Passagen zur Netzneutralität drin.
Wobei jetzt auch keine einhellige Unterstützung auf allen Seiten zu hören war, weil teilweise in dem eigentlichen Beschlussprozess, den die brasilianische Regierung anstrebt, auch noch eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung vorgesehen ist. Also da ist jetzt auch noch nicht alles wunderbar. Andererseits muss man auch berücksichtigen, Brasilien ist halt so ein Land, was einerseits den USA ordentlich Kante gezeigt hat in dieser ganzen Snowden-Debatte und ja auch Snowden offiziell Asyl angeboten hat. Ob er das jemals in der Lage ist einzulösen, werden wir sehen. Keine Ahnung. Also dass das, sagen wir mal, dieser Gesamtkontext, der hier stattgefunden hat, wichtig zu verstehen ist, diese Konferenz ist non-binding. Es gibt da zwar ein Abschlussdokument, aber das ist sozusagen so ein Naja, wir haben uns jetzt mal hier zusammengesetzt, wir haben uns mal was überlegt, wie das hier irgendwie laufen könnte und so ist es. Aber das ist jetzt alles noch nichts, was jetzt unmittelbar später in Gesetze gegossen wird.
Nur um es zu trennen. Also einmal das eine war die Marco Civil da Internet.
Das ist brasilianische Geschichte. Das andere ist Net Mundial. Die Veranstaltung, die stattgefunden hat, zu deren Anlass die brasilianische Regierung da ihre künftigen Prinzipien versucht hat an die Wand zu pinnen. Genau.
Und in der Marco Civil steht eben auch eine sechsmonatige Vorratsdatenspeicherung mit drin.
Und das ist aber noch nicht beschlossen?
Doch, Marco Civil ist beschlossen. Haben sie zum Auftakt der Net Mundial beschlossen. Feierlich. Haben wir gesagt, hallo willkommen.
Ja, beschlossen, dass sie das machen wollen, aber nicht, dass das jetzt schon Gesetz ist.
Selbstverständlich. Das Gesetz wurde von der Präsidentin verabschiedet, oder vom Parlament beschlossen. Und das zum Auftakt dieser Net Mundial. Das ist ein bisschen verwirrend.
Ja, ist es.
Aber jetzt kommen also die Zivilgesellschaft, die Vertreter der Zivilgesellschaft, kommen also enttäuscht zurück und ärgern sich über dieses Abschlussdokument. Andererseits ist es erstmal non-binding, aber zeigt halt diesen Aspekt, in welche Richtung es da jetzt geht. Und der Konflikt ist jetzt auch nicht neu.
Ja, mehr haben wir da nicht zu sagen, oder? Vielleicht holen wir das Gespräch darüber nochmal nach in einer der kommenden Sendungen. Wenn da noch mehr Einblicke gibt, wie dieser Prozess auch weiter läuft. Genau.
So, dann gab es eine sehr schöne Meldung, über die habe ich mich natürlich gefreut. E-Mail made in Germany. Ich habe da ja, wie gesagt, beim 30C3 irgendwie ein bisschen drüber referiert. Mich dann ansonsten seitdem eigentlich zu dem Thema zurückgehalten. Aber jetzt wird gerade, also die Initiative E-Mail made in Germany ist quasi jetzt in gewisser Form abgeschlossen. Also die Vollverschlussung des Transportweges ist jetzt erreicht. Am 29.04. wurde das feierlich verkündet. Natürlich werden die E-Mails auf den Servern aller beteiligten Unternehmen nach wie vor unverschlüsselt vorgehalten. Das heißt, wie gesagt, wir hatten das ja als CCC damals ausführlich schon kritisiert, als die Idee aufkam. Das heißt, es wird ein Standard umgesetzt, den es seit annähernd 20 Jahren gibt, den eigentlich auch jeder in der Form nutzt, der was auf sich hält, bis auf die deutschen Anbieter, die im Prinzip aus dem Aufholen hier eine riesige Werbekampagne machen. Neu mit dazu haben sie jetzt genommen 1&1 und Strato. Und die bieten dir E-Mails made in Germany auch für eigene Domains an. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt irgendwie deine E-Mail bei Strato hostest, dann kannst auch du mit deiner so-und-so E-Mail at Strato oder at timstrato.de oder was E-Mail made in Germany sein. Das musst du dann extra aktivieren. Das heißt, da machst du ein Häkchen und wenn man das extra aktivieren muss, dann heißt das wahrscheinlich auch, dass da irgendwie noch ein kleines Preisschild dran klebt. Das habe ich aber jetzt noch nicht weiter eruiert, weil ich auch nicht bei Strato oder 1&1 hoste. Wer macht das schon? Und das Spannende ist, auch du, mein Sohn Tim, kannst e-mail made in Germany sein, obwohl ich ja weiß, dass du sicherlich deinen Mail-Server selber hostest oder hosten lässt bei e-mail. Und dafür hat der TÜV jetzt die Möglichkeit, du kannst dich TÜV zertifizieren lassen.
Wirklich?
Der TÜV kommt dann und prüft, ob du die technischen, processualen und organisatorischen Sicherheitsanfangen erfüllst, um e-mail made in Germany an deine E-Mails dranschreiben zu können.
Also der TÜV stellt sozusagen sicher, dass da meine Kommunikation, mein Hin und Her, mein ganzer Transport sicher ist.
Also die kommen im Prinzip und gucken, ob du das Flag gesetzt hast, dass du IMAP über TLS sprichst. Und dann sagen sie, hat er, ist in Ordnung. Und dann kommt natürlich noch, soviel muss man ihnen zugestehen, vermute ich, ein manueller Prozess hinzu, der dann auch das Zertifikat, welches du nutzt, in einen bestimmten Pool aufnimmt, damit dann auch sichergestellt wird, dass wenn du eine E-Mail schreibst, das dann auch schön im Webbrowser-Window des GMX-Nutzers, an dem du diese E-Mail geschrieben hast, dran steht tim.britlove.com, E-Mail made in germany..org..org, ja, ich wollte jetzt extra, ich wollte jetzt nicht extra, sonst kriegst du natürlich die ganzen E-Mails jetzt.
Da krieg ich eh.
So, und das heißt jetzt, hat sich sogar noch der TÜV für diesen Fock Mist hergegeben, der TÜV. Und dann hat der TÜV eine Mail an Heise geschrieben, mit irgendwie seiner Pressemitteilung. Ey jo, hier, wir machen jetzt hier E-Mail Made in Germany Zertifizierung. Und diese E-Mail, also der entscheidende Punkt bei E-Mail Made in Germany ist ja, dass die Server untereinander TLS sprechen. Und diese E-Mail kam dann vom TÜV-Server natürlich beim Heise-Mail-Server an. Und dann haben die Heiseleute gesagt, gucken wir doch mal, wie dieser Server sich zu uns connectet hat und er hat kein TLS genutzt.
Das liegt aber einfach nur daran, dass der TÜV sich zu dem Zeitpunkt einfach noch nicht selbst zertifiziert hat.
Genau, wie soll der TÜV sich auch selber zertifizieren?
Der ist auch so damit beschäftigt, anderen Leuten. Also ich meine, wenn ich mich da jetzt bewerbe, dann kriege ich quasi so vom TÜV die offizielle Bestätigung, dass ich da quasi unfallfrei unterwegs bin und dass irgendwie nichts passieren kann. Kriege ich dann auch so eine Christophorus-Plakette für E-Mail?
Wahrscheinlich. Und wahrscheinlich musst du dich nach jedem System-Update da neu zertifizieren lassen. Also mir sind die TÜV-Prozesse nicht, also wie man sich vom TÜV zertifizieren lässt, ist mir aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht bekannt. Erstens ist es wahrscheinlich zu teuer, als dass ich jemals in die Nähe käme, das auch nur zum Spaß mal machen zu können. Zweitens, im IT-Bereich ist der TÜV, denke ich, inzwischen als nicht kompetent erwiesen. Also alles, wo jemals mit IT-TÜV dran stand, das war jetzt eher eine Lachnummer. Aber der TÜV hat natürlich sein Business, dass man Dinge zertifiziert. Und wenn sie zertifizieren sollen, dass du eine bestimmte Einstellung an deinem Mailserver vorgenommen hast, dann machen die das natürlich. Vor allem, wenn da eine schöne Werbekampagne von der Deutschen Telekom und United Internet hinterhängt. Jetzt kommt aber ein wichtiger Hinweis, den man an dieser Stelle jetzt auch nicht mehr verbergen darf. Das TLS zwischen Mailservern ist nicht so, wie man es von Browsern kennt. Bei Browsern hat man ja diese Zertifikatemafia. Das heißt, jeder Anbieter mit einem Webserver kann ein Zertifikat für sich ausstellen und selber signieren lassen oder vom Freund signieren lassen. Das Entscheidende ist, ein normaler Browser wird dieses Zertifikat immer bemängeln, solange es nicht von einer Zertifizierungsinstanz noch mal signiert ist, der dieser Browser vertraut. Ich möchte das jetzt relativ kurz halten, aber in jedem Browser sind also so um die 200 oder sonst was. Ich habe es länger her, als ich das letzte Mal geguckt habe, ein paar hundert Zertifizierungsinstanzen vorinstalliert, denen der Browser grundsätzlich traut. Da sind im Prinzip Zertifizierungsinstanzen rund um die Welt bei, auch irgendwelche israelischen und natürlich eine ganze Menge US-amerikanische und russische. Dieses Vertrauen ist quasi in euren Browser eingebaut, wenn ihr den runterladet, was auch der Hauptkritikpunkt an diesem ganzen Modell ist. Es hat aber zumindest den Vorteil, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass diese CAS nicht kompromittiert sind, was wie gesagt schon eine falsche Annahme ist, dass es eine dritte Instanz gibt, die zumindest bürgt, wenn auch mit vielen Fehlern im Prozess, dass dieses Zertifikat, das dir gerade die Gegenseite zeigt, auch das ist, was die Gegenseite besitzt. Wie gesagt, technisch ist dieser Prozess sehr anfällig, aber grundsätzlich gibt es ihn, und das gibt es bei Mail erstmal nicht. Das heißt, in dem Moment der Zustellung einer E-Mail sagt der Mail-Server, spricht mit der anderen IP-Adresse und sagt, hallo, lass uns mal verschlüsselt übertragen, und der antwortende Mail-Server sagt dann, wunderbar, nehmen wir dieses Zertifikat hier, und dann sagt der andere, ja, alles klar, machen wir. Das heißt, prinzipiell in der Grundeinstellung ist auch diese Verschlüsselung erstmal relativ wertlos, weil sie halt ohne weiteres man in the middle erlaubt. Weil sie ohne weiteres erlaubt, dass in der Mitte jemand sitzt und ein anderes Zertifikat hinhält und dann in der Mitte einfach mithört. Das heißt, es gibt keinen Garant dafür, dass der einliefernde Server und der empfangende Server ein geteiltes Geheimnis haben, was vor einem Mann in der Mitte schützt.
Aber da war natürlich E-Mail made in Germany sicherlich gedacht.
So ist in der Tat die Hypothese, dass sie das tatsächlich gemacht haben. Denn das könnte erklären, warum man E-Mail made in Germany selber aktivieren muss und sich eventuell selber dafür zertifizieren muss. Und wenn sie es halbwegs vernünftig gemacht haben, werden dann die Zertifikate auf einem nicht benannten, sicheren Wege in den jeweiligen anderen Mailservern bekannt gemacht. Sodass der Mailserver sagt, von dieser IP für diesen Host erwarte ich folgendes Zertifikat. Und wenn dieses Zertifikat mir da nicht präsentiert wird, dann gehe ich davon aus, dass hier ein Problem vorliegt. Aber Hypothese, ich weiß nicht, ob sie es machen. Wenn sie es vernünftig machen, dann würde man es so machen. Und das macht man teilweise auch unter jetzt...
Ja, wenn ich bitte dich, es ist TÜV-zertifiziert.
Ich habe keine... ne, da kann ich nichts zu sagen. TÜV kann ich... weiß ich nicht, wen die da... Also, das ist ja nur ein Witz. Das ist ja nur ein Witz. Da äußere ich mich doch nicht zu. Aber immerhin, also um mal zu sagen, die Hypothese steht im Raum, dass sie das nutzen. Es gibt noch andere Methoden, man kann auch DNS-Tech dafür nutzen, das also im DNS-Eintrag signiert von einer anderen Instanz drin steht, hier erwartest du folgendes Zertifikat des Mail-Servers.
Oder, um das mal ein bisschen menschenkompatibler zu erklären, es gibt durchaus Wege, heutzutage im Internet auch noch parallel irgendwo bekannt zu geben. Das ist genau das Zertifikat, was ich hier verwende. Wenn ihr nicht genau bei der Verbindung auf dieses Zertifikat stößt, dann ist wohl was im Busch. Das ist auch eine Technik, von der wir, glaube ich, das fordern wir, dass das möglichst schnell umgesetzt wird. Das heißt, sowohl, dass es angeboten wird, als auch, dass es überprüft wird. Das ist ein langer Weg, aber das muss jetzt kommen.
Genau, und man könnte also, wenn man mal was Positives sagen soll zu E-Mail Made in Germany, sie scheinen AES-256 zu nutzen. Sie machen auch einen Keyer Exchange, sodass er Perfect Forward Secrecy hat. Und es steht eben jetzt von mir und anderen die Hypothese im Raum, dass sie auch die Zertifikate validieren. Das ist aber die Frage, ob sie es tun, vermutlich dann auch irgendwie manuell. Das könnte diese Wartezeiten rechtfertigen. Aber wichtig hier, das sind Hypothesen. Kritik an dem Punkt ist immer noch, dass es wie gesagt ein Standard ist, der seit Jahren existiert, den sie vorher nicht umgesetzt haben. Und wo sie jetzt quasi nur das aufholen, was man schon länger hätte haben können. Und daraus auch noch eine große Werbekampagne machen. Denn was ich von einem Mailserver-Admin erwarte, ist, dass er sowieso sich darum kümmert, dass erstens der Mailserver das anbietet. Viele Mailserver sind sowieso so konfiguriert, dass sie nur verschlüsselte Verbindungen annehmen. Und was dann der Mailserver-Admin macht, der was auf sich hält, ist im Prinzip zu sagen, ok, ich als Administrator dieses Mailservers traue bei jeder ersten Verbindung zu einem anderen Mailserver genau dem Zertifikat und möchte dann Bescheid bekommen, wenn sich dieses ändert. Was so das Trust on First Use, wo man also sagt, wahrscheinlich wird der Man in the Middle nicht beim ersten Mal dazwischen hängen. Und genau in dem Moment traue ich diesem Zertifikat und dann möchte ich gerne Bescheid wissen, wenn sich das ändert. Das ist also eine Herangehensweise, ohne eine dritte Instanz dann halbwegs davon ausgehen zu können, dass diese Verbindungen verschlüsselt sind. Also wie gesagt, man braucht nach wie vor dieses Email Made in Germany nicht. Es ist totaler Unsinn und was sich hier abzeichnet ist und das finde ich da spannend. Offensichtlich setzen sie jetzt diese Sicherheit ein und wollen ihre komische Marke Email Made in Germany da etablieren, weigern sich aber mit anderen Mail-Servern Verschlüsse zu kommunizieren, die genau die gleiche Verschlüsselung genauso gut, genauso schön zum Einsatz bringen. Und das einfach nur schon länger. Vielleicht machen sie es dann sogar verschlüsselt mit denen, geben den Nutzer aber nicht an, dass hier mit gerade ein Sicherheitsniveau erreicht wurde, was genauso hoch ist. Das heißt, sie versuchen da wieder irgendwie so einen komischen Hack, um irgendeinen Marketing-Label zu etablieren. Und das schmeckt einfach nicht.
Sicher ist es nur, wenn es von uns kommt, nicht wenn es wirklich verschlüsselt ist.
Genau. Sicher ist es nicht, wenn es von der Konkurrenz kommt, die das Ganze schon seit Jahren viel besser als wir machen.
Was ich auch so ein bisschen stinkig finde an dieser Sache, ich meine, mit diesem Made in Germany versucht man natürlich auch so dieses Gefühl zu erwecken, in Deutschland wäre es ja nun ohnehin besonders toll, weil Deutschland ja so geil ist im Bereich Internet. Die Wahrheit ist einfach, dieses Land ist hinterher. Wir sind sehr weit davon entfernt, in irgendeiner Form Vorbildcharakter zu haben, was technische Implementierung, Software und so weiter betrifft. Mir würde jetzt aus dem Stand nicht viel einfallen, was Deutschland irgendwie kulturell oder gar staatlich organisiert oder auch nur aus dem kommerziellen Raum dem Internet groß gespendet hat oder irgendwie besser macht als der Rest. Man läuft da einfach hinterher und auch diese ganze Aktion. Ich meine, vor drei Jahren hätte ich ja gesagt, okay, super Nummer. Aber nach diesem ganzen Snowden-Desaster war es schon so ein bisschen so too little, too late mäßig.
Ich habe das ja schon, also bei dem 30C3 dann noch mal konkret beim Jahresrückblick kritisiert und auch schon vorher immer mal wieder angedeutet. Die deutschen Unternehmen haben jetzt im Prinzip diesen ganzen Internetkram, der kam irgendwie auf und sie haben es irgendwie ja größtenteils verkackt, diesen Markt irgendwie sich zu erschließen.
Kein Cloud, nichts.
Alles, was im Internet geil ist, kommt nicht aus Deutschland. So und dann haben sie ja schon vor Snowden irgendwie dann, da hat das BSI ja angefangen mit dieser Cloud-Richtlinie, die ich dann immer mal wieder zitiere, die interessiert aber außer mir niemanden, wo sie also gesagt haben, ja hier deutsche Cloud muss sein, dann machen wir eine schöne BSI-Zertifizierung, bauen irgendwas ein, dass die Amerikaner nicht haben können oder nicht anbieten, zertifizieren dann deutsche Cloud-Anbieter, allen voran T-Systems und dann machen wir vielleicht noch irgendwie eine Regulation, dass wir sagen, ab einem gewissen Sicherheitsniveau für irgendwelche besonderen Zertifikate mit einem Adler oder einer schwarz-rot-goldenen Farbkombination drin, Bande Role, Pipapo, muss das erfüllt sein und dann machen wir das zu einem Werbeinstrument, damit wenigstens die deutschen Kunden uns nicht abwandern in die USA, wenn wir schon weit davon entfernt sind, überhaupt Kunden aus anderen Ländern zu bekommen. Und das ist natürlich das, was jetzt kommerziell gerade genau ausgenutzt wird an dieser ganzen Snowden-Geschichte. Und ich muss auch sagen, ich fände das ja noch nicht mal schlimm, wenn sie was Vernünftiges machen würden. Als Kritiker kann ich ja immer nur, oder ich gehe natürlich grundsätzlich immer nur hin und sage da, wo es scheiße ist. Ich stelle mich ja jetzt nicht hin und sage, wo es gut ist.
Aber es gibt durchaus, so wie Marcel Reichranditzki schon immer sagte, wie sind Sie als Kritiker, wo ich mich immer so viel Dreck befasse.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch Angebote, die ein sehr viel höheres Sicherheitsniveau bringen. Die gibt es auch im kommerziellen Bereich, die gibt es aber natürlich vor allem im nicht-komerziellen Bereich. Das Hauptproblem, das ich sehe, ist, dass die Sicherheitsangebote, die jetzt gemacht werden, weiterhin an den Anbieter gebunden sind. Und echte Sicherheit ist immer losgelöst vom Anbieter, denn echte Sicherheit bedeutet, dass der Anbieter egal wird. Und das ist natürlich auch die kommerzielle Klemme, in der sich jetzt die Unternehmen befinden, dass sie sagen, ja, wir müssen ja irgendwie noch was bauen, was die Menschen an uns als Anbieter bindet, weil wir sind ja nun mal Anbieter.
Probiert es mal mit ordentlichen Preisen und gutem Service und fairer Behandlung.
Ja, und dann könnte er nebenbei noch dafür sorgen, dass es ein vernünftiger Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüssel gibt. Und schon könnte aus der ganzen Sache was werden. Naja, die Gedanken werde ich nächste Woche auch nochmal äußern im Bundestagsausschuss Digitale Agenda. Da komme ich gleich am Ende nochmal zu.
Live von den Farben?
Mir wurde ein Livestream versprochen. Keine Ahnung, ich stand in der Einladung, glaube ich. Der Balthasar Glättli aus der Schweiz hat sechs Monate Vorratsdaten sich erklagt, auf dem gleichen Wege, wie es der Grünen-Politiker Malte Spitz getan hat, und hat sie dann auch den gleichen Leuten in die Hand gedrückt, nämlich den Jungs von Open Data City. Die aufmerksamen Hörerinnen wissen, dass da unter anderem der Michael Kreil in diesem Team arbeitet, der bei uns auch schon zu Gast war. Damals war das doch zu Zugdaten, die er veröffentlicht hatte, als er bei uns zu Gast war.
Da haben wir, glaube ich, über die Offenlegung der Zug-CD der Deutschen Bahn gesprochen. Und er hat auch diverse andere Projekte begleitet. Er ist jetzt auch wieder ganz fleißig mit der Republik und den Daten, immer einiges zu holen. Ich muss noch erwähnen, wer Balthasar Glättli ist. Er ist auch ein Politiker, und zwar der Grünen. GPS heißt es ja lustigerweise, Grüne Partei der Schweiz. Also die können sich auf jeden Fall gut verorten. Und es ist da jetzt vorangeschritten, noch mal eine ähnliche Geschichte zu machen.
Kurz den Anlass, die Schweiz hat ja schon eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und die Debatte, die gerade in der Schweiz geführt ist, dass man sagt, ja wir haben eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, aber es sind ja nur sechs Monate. Wir wollen aber lieber zwölf, um die Aufklärungsraten für Verbrechen hoch zu bekommen. Interessanterweise hat die Schweiz aber schlechtere Aufklärungsraten als Deutschland. Und Deutschland hat ja noch nicht mal eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und da gibt es jetzt eine Petition, die wir natürlich alle Beteiligten bitten zu unterzeichnen. In der Schweiz, die verlinken wir dann auch. Und als Argumentationshandreichung empfehle ich da auch nochmal die acht Mythen von Thomas Stadler betreffend die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Wo er also die acht häufig gehörten Argumente für eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung dann nochmal sinnvoll entkräftet. Denn wir erinnern uns ja an die Worte von Hans-Christian Sturble. Der Kampf geht weiter, könnte man eigentlich sagen. Das war Rudi Dutschke am Grab von Holger Mainz, mein ich. Oder war das?
Da bin ich jetzt nicht geschichtsfest.
Doch, da bin ich ja sehr geschichtsfest. Das habe ich ja gar nicht in der Folge gesagt.
Nimm mal die geballte Faust drunter, dann kannst du auch besser tippen.
Das war, glaube ich, Holger, der Kampf geht weiter.
Mythos 1, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist zur Aufklärung von Straftaten unverzichtbar. Mythos 2, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung dient nur der Bekämpfung schwerster Straftaten. Mythos 3, bei der VDS werden nur Verbindungsdaten gespeichert. Mythos 4, in Norwegen hat VDS zur schnellen Aufklärung von dem Fall Anders Breivik beigetragen. Das hatten wir ja auch schon mal, dass dem nicht so ist. Mythos 5, ohne VDS könnten Straftaten im Internet nicht mehr aufgeklärt werden. Mythos 6, der Polizei müssen alle technischen möglichen Instrumentarien auch zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Das ist auch etwas, was man häufiger in der Debatte immer wieder hört. Mythos 7, eine verfassungskonforme Neuregelung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung wäre problemlos möglich. Mythos 8, Deutschland hat durch die Nichtumsetzung der VDS nach dem Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts gegen Europarecht verstoßen. Das sind die Punkte, auf die er sich bezieht. Alles Talking Points, die man häufiger mal hört in Debatten, eigentlich laufend. Und da gibt es dann noch ein bisschen Munition für den Hobby-Argumentierer. Damit ihr auf den Partys, in denen ihr in der Küche steht, mit der Bierflasche in der Hand auch noch was in die Runde schmeißen könnt. An eure sicherlich politisch aufgeschlossenen und zu so komplexen Themenmaß wie VDS gerne diskutierenden Freunde.
Wir beenden die Sendung mit einem kurzen Lacher. Es war die USA bekannt gegeben, dass sie Exploits eigentlich grundsätzlich nicht zurückhält. Also dass sie schon abwägen, wenn sie jetzt eine Kenntnis über eine große Sicherheitslücke sagen, nennen wir sie Heartbleed-Hatton, dass sie dann sagen, naja, wir wägen dann schon ab, ob diese Sicherheitslücke in der Hand von anderen Menschen, dem politischen oder außenpolitischen Gegner, eventuell zu gefährlich ist. Dann können wir schon zu dem Gedanken kommen, die Öffentlichkeit über die Sicherheitslücke, die wir da gefunden haben, zu informieren. Allerdings verhalten wir alle Sicherheitslücken geheim, wenn sie sich für den Kampf gegen den Terror eignen. Also, ne Quatsch, Entschuldigung, Sie haben es natürlich anders formuliert. Sie sagen, wenn sich eine Sicherheitslücke für den Kampf gegen den Terror eignet, dann halten wir sie geheim. Wenn man jetzt mal die Definition von Kampf gegen den Terror, die die USA in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren hochhalten anschaut, dann ist es relativ schwer für eine Sicherheitslücke in einem Computer, sei sie wie auch immer geartet, in die Kategorie zu fallen, die nicht für den Kampf gegen den Terror geeignet ist. Das fand ich sehr schön formuliert.
Ja, ich frage mich auch, was das ist. Ich frage mich vor allem auch, ob von der NSA eigentlich überhaupt schon mal irgendwelche Exploits als solche bekanntgegeben wurden. Also da kann ich mich nicht so richtig dran erinnern.
Das ist ein Geheimdienst. Wir haben hier so ein bisschen Oday, den verbrennen wir jetzt mal kurz, weil wir können uns nicht vorstellen, dass wir den für den Kampf gegen den Terror brauchen. Das ist lächerlich. Aber das zeigt, wir haben da auch mal eine Folge gehabt, wo wir relativ ausführlich über den Handel mit IT-Sicherheitslücken gesprochen haben. Allerdings bei Weipen nicht so ausführlich wie der FX bei Alternativlos. Das heißt, da kann man, glaube ich, beide Folgen sollten inhaltlich wahrscheinlich deckungsgleich ungefähr sein. FX natürlich länger mal sprechen. Also ich habe, glaube ich, mich ein bisschen mehr über die politischen Implikationen ausgelassen und FX sich mehr über die technischen.
Schon ein bisschen länger her, die Folgen.
Ja, ja, es ist länger her. Wir haben ja inzwischen über 100 Folgen.
Nicht nur unsere, sondern auch die von Alternativlos.
Ja, Alternativlos erscheint ja eh nicht besonders. Für diejenigen, die es nicht mitbekommen haben, ich war da ja zu Gast.
In der letzten Folge.
In der letzten Folge, Alternativlos. Somit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angelangt.
Nächste Woche ist Republika. Das bedeutet, wir sind alle sehr eingebunden. Da wird es wahrscheinlich keine Logbuch Netzpolitik Sendung geben, nehme ich mal an.
Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr unwahrscheinlich. Wenn, dann spontan. Also müssen wir mal schauen. Tim macht ja wieder das Sendezentrum. Ich muss da irgendwie noch in dem Bundestagsausschuss auftreten. Halte auch noch einen kleinen Vortrag bei der Republika.
Sieht nicht gut aus.
Das sieht eng aus, aber vielleicht trifft man ja im Bereich der Republika auf jemanden Interessantes, mit dem man sagt, mit dem müssen wir uns unterhalten. Letztes Jahr war es ja der Martin Delius, dem wir uns unterhalten haben. Vielleicht ergibt sich da was, aber erstmal wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Rechnet nicht damit. Ja, haben wir sonst noch was?
Ja, ich muss mich bedanken. Und zwar bei Jan, Sebastian und Hans Christian. Die drei wissen Bescheid. Meine Wohnung ist jetzt größtenteils voll automatisiert. Kann jede Steckdose fern bedienen. Das ist lustig. Ist auch gar nicht so teuer, kriegt man so Fernbedienungen und dann so Stecker, die in die Steckdose kommen. Damit kann man dann das, was da dran steckt, mit der Fernbedienung ausschalten. Zum Beispiel Lampen. Oder die Stereo-Anlage, die den Podcast über Bluetooth wiedergibt. Das ist zum Beispiel ganz gut.
Das stimmt total sicher auch.
Das Ding ist nicht SSL-verschlüsselt, aber der Key ist 5-Bit. Also du hast so fünf Kippschalter, um dann den Schlüssel... Also es ist relativ überschaubar jetzt. Dann geht das Radio halt aus. Kritische Infrastruktur habe ich da nicht dran angeschlossen. Republika ist angekündigt, Bundestagsausschuss ist angekündigt, bedankt haben wir uns, Themen haben wir alle durch.
Dann bleibt uns nichts anderes als euch spannende Diskussionen auf Partys in der Küche zu wünschen und wir hören uns dann wieder, wenn wir wieder senden.
Und einen schönen revolutionären 1.